I did a series is went viral and then
the eyes are on you.
It was one of the most
viral trends and it obviously boosted my
profile a huge amount.
It has opened doors to do books, get big
investors in the restaurant.
Look at other sites already, be full.
I mean, there's obviously negatives to
anything.
Every article that ever came out, it was
like 'TikTok Star'.
I just found a bit derogatory considering I've
worked in restaurants my whole career.
I grew up in the countryside in
Herefordshire.
You know, we keep the pigs and sheep and
chickens so I grew up understanding
food from a very young age.
The restaurant is called Streaker's.
I don't know how I came up with that
name.
We wanted to create a restaurant that
was, you know, neighborhood first and
foremost with the good energy, relaxed
vibe.
But serious. Good food.
Great music.
Comfortable seats.
I was confident in the fact that we
could create a successful restaurant.
We haven't really compromised on the
quality of the ingredients.
We've got langoustines, scallops we have turbot
on, but we have to take it off because
it's 50 quid a kilo at the moment.
All of the mollusks like mussels and
clams and stuff like that are pretty
inexpensive.
So we've got a flatbread with muscle butter,
and that is absolutely delicious,
one the best sellers. Anything with
flour and water is a winner.
The restaurant we've got a few of the
appliances on gas, which is
obviously quite expensive.
We've then got a charcoal grill and a wood-fired
pizza oven, less expensive.
And those big, big items hold residual
heat all night.
So you'll come in the morning,
the pizza was still at 250 degrees.
And I think those pressure for that
like, you know, critics want to be in
to criticize because I've got a profile
and they're like, 'let's see what this
butter guy can do'.
I don't want to get pigeonholed into
doing something.
I think before the content was much more
natural.
It was more food that you could cook at
home, you know, I guess go back to being...
being me.